8 place au débat dalons plus loin
emmanuel macron président aujourd'hui à
l'elysée une réunion ii sur la sortie de
crise pour définir les protocoles
sanitaires nécessaires à la réouverture
des établissements fermés au public
dans ce contexte on va se demander si
l'horizon du 15 mai pour ouvrir
certaines terrasses le culturel et
réaliste il faut dire que les ministres
restent prudents cette date reste
soumise à la situation épidémique
répètent-ils depuis deux jours on en
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
mais d'abord quels sont les scénarii
pour ce début de retour à la vie normale
qui henri albert ball lors de son
allocution il ya quinze jours
emmanuel macron annoncé une date de
réouverture des bars et restaurants et
des lieux de culture
dès la mi mai nous recommencerons à
ouvrir avec des règles strictes certains
lieux de culture nous autoriserons sous
conditions l'ouverture de terrasses et
nous allons bâtir entre la mi mai et le
début de l'été un calendrier de
réouverture progressive pour la culture
le sport les loisirs l'événementiel nos
cafés et restaurants mais depuis la
situation sanitaire ne s'améliore pas à
la haute chambre
le doute plane sur la date de
réouverture je doute un peu sur la date
15 mai il y aura peut-être une ouverture
progressive des terrasses et autres nous
verture total au 15 mai je ne vois pas
comment il pourrait se réaliser
depuis quelques jours les ministres
n'évoque plus la date du 15 mai comme le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire le
15 mai fait partie des hypothèses mais
on suit l'évolution sanitaire la manière
dont circule le virus et dont nous
arrivons à en limiter la circulation
et c'est sur cette base là que les
décisions sont prises ou encore jean
baptiste lemoyne plus président avait
esquissé cet horizon pour le début
des phases de réouverture maintenant
vous avez c'est la situation sanitaire
qui commande pour le sénateur bernard
jomier il faut rouvrir progressivement
certaines activités au fond les exemples
étrangers nous le montrent les données
scientifiques nous le confirme ne sont
pas génératrice d'une des circulations
significative du virus et donc ses
activités là on doit les reprendre quand
il n'y a pas de risques sanitaires
identifiés
on a assez de recul maintenant il n'y a
aucune raison de retarder la reprise
il faut reprendre il faut reprendre vite
quand il ya des risques sanitaires
identifiés
eh bien il faut être plus progressif et
beaucoup plus précautionneux au royaume
uni en espagne au portugal et au
luxembourg les bars et restaurants
accueille de nouveau des clients la
belgique elle va autoriser leur
réouverture à partir du 8 mai est avec
nous pour le grand débat d' allons plus
loin mode brégeon bonjour vous êtes
porte parole de la république en marche
avec nous sur ce plateau pierre laurent
sénateur communiste de paris vice
président du sénat merci de participer à
ce débat est avec nous en visio distance
qu'ovide oblige nous sommes avec eux
gilbert de ray professeur de médecine
chef du service de néphrologie de
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière merci
beaucoup de participer à ce débat et
fabrice bonnot vous êtes chef du
restaurant cuisine et dépendances à lyon
et président de l'association charité
bellecour une association de commerçants
d'une des plus vieilles des plus
vieilles rues de lyon on va commencer
par faire un petit point sur la
situation puisque aujourd'hui jean
castex a annoncé de plutôt bonne
nouvelle car la france vaccine plus que
ce qui était prévu pour le mois d'avril
on écoute le premier ministre cet
après-midi allemand ce soir aujourd'hui
nous sommes le 15 avril alors que
j'avais annoncé que nous serions à 10
millions de françaises et de français
ayant bénéficié d'une première injection
nous devrions être ce soir à 12 millions
deux millions de plus que ce que prévu 7
je crois une action nouvelle
pierre laurent est ce que vous saluer
ceux là sont de bonnes nouvelles 12
millions de personnes qui ont reçu une
injection et puis le premier ministre a
aussi annoncé le vaccin facilité pour
les professions exposées c'est à dire
les enseignants les policiers de plus de
55 ans que vous avez l'impression que ça
avance vous savez vous la mobilisation
au vaccinale général c'est ce que nous
demandons depuis depuis des mois nous
avons même fait des propositions pour
libérer la production ont libéré les
brevets pour pouvoir augmenter la
production de vaccins dont tout ce qui
va dans le sens d'une vaccination plus
importante de la population
évidemment on peut que s'en satisfaire
parce qu'on sait que la vaccination fait
partie des conditions de sortie de la
crise sanitaire mais c'est très sain si
près vous dire que tout ce qui a été
fait en la matière depuis des mois me
satisfait pleinement non non non
l'occasion que j'ai eu souvent
l'occasion de le dire mais tout ce qui
permet d'avancer et d'avancer plus vite
vers la vaccination en france en europe
et dans le monde c'est un sujet de
préoccupation parce que dans le monde ça
n'avance pas assez vite est évidemment
indispensable
et oui il faut dire que on a 12 millions
donc des personnes vaccinées mais dans
le même temps mode région n'a atteint
aujourd'hui cette barre symbolique très
forte et terrible des cent mille morts
que par ailleurs tout n'est pas dispo
tout n'est pas positif sur le front des
vaccins à loin de là entre une certaine
défiance qui est en train de s'installer
à l'égard d'astrazeneca les doutes
désormais à l'instar de johnson &
johnson
ce sont là pour le coup de mauvaises
nouvelles
alors qu'on la dit la vaccination elle
est essentielle pour pouvoir avancer par
la suite depuis le début de cette crise
il ya des bonnes nouvelles vous l'avez
rappelé le premier ministre les a
rappelés aujourd'hui il ya aussi eu des
mauvaises nouvelles notamment sur les
vaccins le sait sur l'astra zeneca on
n'a pas forcément pu l'utiliser comme on
l'aurait voulu maintenant gouverner
c'est pas regarder le lait qui serait
pain sur le sol c'est trouver des
solutions et c'est choisir c'est ce que
fait d'ailleurs le président de la
république il ya 7 millions de doses
supplémentaires qui vont être livrés
d'ici juin c'est ce qu'a annoncé jean
castex aujourd'hui on va franchir la
barre des 12 millions de personnes
vaccinées
donc si effectivement bien sûr c'est un
jour triste parce qu'on passe cette
barge est symbolique mais qui a son
importance
on espère quand même voir le bout du
tunnel et c'est le sens de la
préparation que mène le président de la
république de d'une réouverture alors
partiel évidemment avec des contraintes
et des protocoles sanitaires qui sont
street
mais cette vaccination se déployant on
peut espérer en tout cas on l'espère
tous sortir petit à petit des
contraintes qui sont il faut le rappeler
est extrêmement forte pour nous tous et
tous les français essaient de voile à
cette volonté aussi du président de
faire coexister les différentes
contraintes depuis le départ entre le
lien social le sanitaire et l'économique
gilbert dre comment est ce que vous vous
qualifieriez justement la situation
est ce que pour vous on est au pic de la
troisième vague est ce que les
vaccinations se font à un rythme
satisfaisant quel regard globalement
portez vous aujourd'hui sur la situation
sanitaire
alors il ya beaucoup d'éléments dans ce
que vous dites pour ce qui est de la
vaccination mais à l'avant centre est
torride de disponibilité des vaccins
nous sommes capables de vacciner
beaucoup plus que ça mais nous n'avons
pas les autres c'est un échec européen
qu'on va j'espère effacé dans l'est dans
les prochains mois qui à la fin on
laissera des traces et ne doit nous
inciter à mieux préparer chacun 12
millions de matinée c'est bien mais très
clairement ça ne permet pas d'assurer la
protection ça ne permet pas le lever les
restrictions il n'y a absolument aucune
immunité collective avec 12 millions et
de plus nous allons maintenant
l'expérience en vie réelle de la
grande-bretagne d'israël des états unis
qui montrent que même quand on a vacciné
bien plus de monde que ça et le chili
récemment encore une forte résurgence du
nombre de cas on est loin loin loin
d'avoir la protection ce qui l'amène à
dire que notre situation actuelle étant
extrêmement fragile puisque il a été
choisi de vivre avec ce virus ce kit
ayant la nation et à bonn a envie pas
arrêter la section qu'on a une et aussi
vite avec sing qu on ait un plateau très
élevé
pour l'instant il est extrêmement
difficile de prévoir l'évolution
esquissera enfants à la maison amour non
j'y crois pas un seul instant on parle
beaucoup trop
est-ce que même il est déjà je n'en sais
rien et stressant interprétable et je
trouve que ce qui est extrêmement
difficiles sont les éléments suivants
premièrement derrière tout ce qu'on est
en train de vie à aider à mener est un
des hommes et des femmes et d'un
monsieur sur ses plateaux qui donc d
amende et cinq depuis un an on doit
vérifier souffre de son sommet absolu
reste élevé et que je vais dire ils sont
le coin sanitaire jeu sachez que dans un
coin de ma pensée il y a toujours le
poids de ces hommes et ces femmes que
l'on oublie et qui perdent leur emploi
leur vie et dans des conditions que je
peux même pas imaginer
donc je ne crois pas que l'euro 15 900
dans une situation de déconfit les et je
ne crois pas que les décisions qu'ils
ont prises sur des décisions sanitaire
est d'un autre ordre économique tous que
nous ne serons pas sanitaires et
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas d'indicateurs
qui nous est donné on ne nous dit pas on
va les confiner si sur le plan sanitaire
comment nous nous y aura des confiné ce
qui voudrait dire alors qu'on va
décliner dans des conditions qui
pourraient même que celle actuelle et ce
qui m'amène si vous permet à nexway
augmentèrent plaisanterie et que si on
devait décider s'ils confirment la
situation toujours alors falloir
sérieusement bening et je sais que le
monsieur qui est avec nous sur ce
plateau représentent tous ces
restaurateurs qui sont prêts mais il va
falloir qu conscient un peu imaginatif
et par exemple fait partie de ceux qui
disaient je suis pas faire un restaurant
avec des gens vaccinés et restaurants
servent et mais justement on va en
parler hein
rappelons ce qu'emmanuel macro à
d'ailleurs déclaré le 31 mars à autour
de cette échéance mi mai il a dit dès la
mi-mai nous recommencerons à ouvrir avec
des règles strictes certains lieux de
culture nous autoriserons sous
conditions l'ouverture de terrasse nous
allons bâtir entre la mi-mai
but de l'été un calendrier de
réouverture progressive pour la culture
le sport les loisirs l'événementiel et
nos cafés et restaurants fabrice bonnot
vous est-ce que vu le contexte sanitaire
et vu tout ce que l'on vient de dire sur
ce plateau et notamment gilbert de rêve
vous parvenez vous à vous projeter vers
l'échéance du 15 mai est ce que vous
attendez vraiment des dates précises de
la part de l'exécutif
alors qu'on le voit bien la situation
sanitaire est encore très compliqué
alors oui bonsoir nous sommes très
impatients de réouvrir nos commerces
ça c'est sûr mais par contre il va
falloir être très très prudent
on ne peut pas se permettre aujourd'hui
de réouvrir pour refermer dans quelques
semaines ce n'est pas possible nous
avons besoin d'une annonce forte du
président d'un cas qui nous est donnée
justement pour que l'on puisse préparer
une réouverture
souvenez vous on nous a annoncé le 20
janvier oui ensuite le 6 avril
aujourd'hui le 15 mai je pense qu'il
faut être prudent et vraiment préparé
cette réouverture avec un protocole
strict et des mesures appliquées aussi
bien par le consommateur que par le
professionnel qui va accueillir du
public
mais du coup vous pour me mais vous y
croyez vous que vous avez rappelé et
bien tout de toutes ces échéances que
vous aviez eu auparavant est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que me mais ça va être
faisable non je trouve que c'est
précipité également on vient de le dire
son plateau la vaccination est
indispensable pour pouvoir ré ouvrir nos
lieux publics
donc il va falloir accélérer cette
vaccination peut-être renforcer le
protocole sanitaire pour caen puis
serait ouvert aux ouvriers ouvrir
prochainement mais le 15 mai c'est pas
possible eh bien justement peut-être
peut-on s'inspirer un petit peu de ce
qui se passe à l'étranger
ce lundi 12 avril bien les anglais ont
pu retrouver leurs commerces non
essentiels à l'occasion d'un allègement
des restrictions sanitaires et puis on
va aller voir au luxembourg comment ça
se passe les terrains des restaurants
sont rouvertes avec un protocole bien
précis jérémy à une semaine s'est rendu
sur place regarder
en plus de l'addition il faut
s'acquitter du respect des règles
sanitaires
cette étape de 2 maximum on peut à
l'extrême a ajouté si un enfant dont
vous même foyer
mais sinon c'est table de 2 avec un
mètre cinquante autres chaque table
mais inutile d'imaginer dîner on aurait
préféré le soir quand même mais bon
c'est déjà ça car les restaurants
doivent remballer à 18 heures oui et
rappelons un petit peu que la situation
est quand même bien différente en
luxembourg donc 20% de la population est
vaccinée c'est un pays qui teste 3 à 4
fois plus que et bien ses pays voisins
et pour l'instant la situation est
plutôt sous contrôle 1 il n'y a pas eu
de troisième vague au luxembourg donc je
le disais gilbert de hasni situation
différente mais est ce que cela doit
nous inspirer est-ce que vous pensez que
il ya quand même des enseignements à
tirer de ce type d'expérience à
l'étranger
il faut absolument regarder aussi pas
dans le monde
c'était extrêmement important pour
éviter ce qui vient d'être dit j'ai pas
capté le nom de monsieur de lyon qui
serait de 22 tours fermé et quinze jours
plus tard qu'est ce qui serait
absolument dramatique supposons qu'on
n'ouvre malgré un état sanitaire qui est
plus que préoccupant car je rappelle à
vendre répondre que ce qui pour
l'instant marche c'est un confinement
dur de deux mois et la création massive
n'est pas dans cette situation n'étant
pas dans cette situation
ce qu'il faudrait c'est qu'on est
plusieurs éléments combinés premièrement
oui conteste de façon extrêmement
importante et régulière en se servant
peut-être des autotests qu'il pourrait
nous aider à essayer de dépister un peu
plus massivement alors en particulier
dans les écoles si on pouvait faire deux
thèses par semaine de façon répétée
social extrêmement utile si on prend le
problème la restauration par exemple été
assez compact et terrasse soit fermé il
faut que ce soit des terrasses qui sont
ouverts et effectivement que toutes les
mesures de distance respectable
malheureusement je dois rappeler que
lorsqu'on a fait ça et quelques mois
avec un respect ces mesures
malheureusement la circulation virale
était tellement élevé qu'on n'est pas
arrivé à contrôler la situation
correctement
donc j'espère qu'on va y arriver
honnêtement j'espère parce que je suis
désespéré de voir tous ces commerces qui
sont fermées je n'ose imaginer la
détresse qu'il y a derrière
je ne suis pas confiant pour le 15 mai
j'ai voulu répéter parce qu'on parle
beaucoup trop c'est pas le bon moment
est ce que je ne voudrais pas qu'il
serait pire que tout c'est qu'on nous le
casse mais pour des raisons qui ne sont
pas sanitaires et qu'on referme 15 jours
ou un mois plus tard la case fabrice
bonnot vous travaillez vous sur des
protocoles sanitaires qu'est ce que vous
prévoyez qu'est ce que vous prévoyez
précisément quel quel jour j'ai ce que
vous prévoyez peut-être aussi est ce que
pour vous ce serait une bonne chose de
n'accepter des clients qu'avec une sorte
de passe annie terre avec des passes
avec des tests négatifs ou des vaccins
par exemple à berlin aujourd'hui il faut
un test négatif pour entrer dans un
magasin on le sent il va falloir
beaucoup beaucoup se tester en attendant
de pouvoir avoir un vrai taux de
vaccination dans la population
alors peut-être un test négatif mais
d'imposer le vaccin notre clientèle je
me vois pas du tout imposer une
vaccination pour les gens qui vont
pénétrer dans nos dans nos lieux dans
nos restaurants
peut-être des tests salivaires peut-être
des tests plus efficace et plus rapide
que l'on pourra demander à notre notre
clientèle on a montré depuis le début
que notre profession a su s'adapter
on a su mettre en place des protocoles
sanitaires strictes
donc il faut pas oublier aussi consomme
car mais depuis six mois et que le virus
continue à circuler
pierre jamet donc la restauration est au
point d'arrêt les bars et restaurants
c'est tout fermé donc aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que le virus continue à
circuler et très vite
oui donc je pense qu'il faut renforcer
les mesures que nous avions déjà mis en
place lors du premier des confinement et
peut-être des épurateurs d'air peut-être
des qr codes à l'entrée justement qui
donnent des informations
et puis continuer à appliquer ces
mesures mais il faut qu'elles soient
strictes ces mesures il faut qu'elle
soit appliquée par le commerçant mais
aussi comprise par le consommateur c'est
très important
pierre laurent est ce que pour vous il
faut absolument conditionné et bien ces
réouvertures à la situation épidémique
c'est ça me paraît évident on veut dire
personne ne va plaider pour
pour ouvrir et ouvrir n'importe comment
sans tenir compte de la situation
sanitaire qui reste comme l'a dit
gilbert de ré extrêmement extrêmement
inquiétante
ce qui est un peu pénible il faut le
dire c'est qu'on discute de la date du
15 mai salle date a été décidée a
discuté avec personne
annoncé par le président de la
république puis après on fait débat tout
le monde une date qui n'a pas été
préparée que d'ailleurs les ministres
sont beaucoup sont bien plus prudents
aujourd'hui ils disent 15 c'est que
depuis le début c'est comme ça donc
c'est assez pénible pour tout le monde
je pense pour la population
pour les responsables politiques qui
parfois on demande de voter sur des
décisions qui sont déjà prises et c'est
donc soit arrêté de travailler comme ça
je dirais de travailler collectivement
comme ça donc évidemment on sent bien
que il faut sortir de cette situation il
ya des conditions sanitaires comme elles
vont pas se lever miraculeusement
quelques semaines parce que le rythme de
vaccination n'est pas suffisamment
important est que le niveau de
contamination n'est pas assez
redescendus il faut des conditions
alors il ya des conditions sanitaires
qui sont à discuter entre les
professions et et le gouvernement en
lien avec les indications sanitaires je
veux souligner quand même qui a une
autre dimension qu'il faut pendant qu'on
ne sait pas parce qu'on va réouvrir que
l'ensemble des lieux de culture des des
activités qui sont aujourd'hui fermées
vont retrouver une activité normale
donc il faut des plans de soutien qui
reste très élevé très élevé pour
accompagner cette reprise qui de toute
façon va être lente et progressive je
prends l'exemple des lieux de culture je
pense qu'il ya des choses qui sont allés
pour vous pour l'instant ce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont impossibles pour
réouvrir les lieux de culture
progressivement avec des jauges avec des
mesures sanitaires
je pense que ça ferait du bien à tout le
monde évidemment aux professionnels de
culture mais aussi à toute la population
mais il faut de toute façon il faut une
année blanche supplémentaire pour les
droits des intermittents et il faut un
plan de soutien massif aux
établissements de culture et aux
professions culturelles
parce que de toute façon la situation va
encore durer et je pense que c'est vrai
évidemment ce que je dis pour les lieux
de culture
c'est vrai pour d'autres en profession
donc pas aussi de mesures qui couperait
brutalement ddn ou ne l'est prolongerait
pas alors qu'on sait qu'on est
malheureusement dans une situation même
si on va vers des réouvertures qui vont
être qu'ils vont être lente et
progressive moins deux régions est ce
que il faut encore s'engager sur une
date alors que les manuels macron avait
promis de manière précipitée les jours
heureux
alors qu'on avait parlé d' un
desserrement d'un retour à la normale
pour mi-avril maintenant on nous parle
de mi mai il faut peut-être arrêter de
donner des dates alors quand on voit à
quel point il est difficile de les
respecter aujourd'hui le l'évocation de
mi avril n'avait pas été prononcé par le
président de la république là et bien là
il avait durant évoqué lors d'un
déplacement dans tant de merveilles dans
sa phase et s'est engagé à sa auprès des
français alors évidemment c'est
conditionné à une situation sanitaire
évidemment que tout ne va pas réouvrir
le 15 mai sans protocole
alors je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui
réouvrira dans quelle mesure mais ce
sera évidemment de façon contrainte pour
autant moi je pense qu'on a beaucoup de
retours d'expérience maintenant sur ce
virus on sait par exemple que les
contaminations à l'extérieur sont
moindres que les contaminations au
milieu confiné on a le retour
d'expérience des pays voisins et à part
tout en europe et dans le monde
nous on peut s'inspirer ont commencé
pour certains une réouverture est donc
ça nous apprend aussi tout ça des choses
et ça n'a pas pris d'ailleurs du retard
là dessus quand on voit qu'il ya eu des
cancers ce que reste qui était prévu il
a été obligé d'être angoissé jeu qu'on a
seulement réussi à faire à mon sens il
écrira j'ai pas d'agrégation en
immunologie mai
on était quand même dans une situation
sanitaire et on l'est toujours qui était
et qui est très inquiétante et donc est
ce que c'était le moment de faire ses
expérimentations là alors comprenez des
contraintes supplémentaires
j'en suis pas sûr la priorité du
président de la république pendant cette
crise c'est ça reste sa première volonté
de protéger les français et donc le
sanitaire a primé sur le reste
maintenant après 12 mois de crise la
fatigue collective les dégâts la
précarité que ça engendre aussi sont
tous assez des données à prendre en
compte je crois dans l'équation
et puis les efforts qui ont été faits
sur l'ouverture de lits de réanimation
les gérants parler de 50 lits de
réanimation qui ouvre chaque jour les
tests plusieurs millions par semaine qui
continue à se déployer sur le plan
économique le quoi qu'il en coûte aussi
les aides bruno le maire a rappelé à
plusieurs reprises que bien sûr elle
perdurera tant que nécessaire et que y
aurait pas de 2,2 fin que le robinet ne
serait pas me fermer de façon brutale et
donc ça c'est je pense très important
pour conclure vince intéressé a aussi un
petit peu ce qui se joue politiquement
avec cette crise car ce qu'on a bien
compris bien c'est que le bilan du
quinquennat se fera a priori beaucoup
sur les questions sanitaires et
d'ailleurs tout faux pas est beaucoup
commentée par l'opposition écouté ce
matin le président du groupe union
centriste au sénat il était l'invité
dorian mancini dans bonjour chez vous
hervé marseille
ce qui est dommageable c'est qu'il
faille toujours pointé du doigt exécutif
pour qu'ils prennent des mesures
ça a été le cas sur l'auto test il ya
quinze jours gouvernement ne voulait pas
se saisir les autotests alors que ça se
fait dans beaucoup d'autres pays
et puis on a fini par le faire en retard
dans la précipitation on a fini par le
faire parce que on a libre maroc et
c'est important et là on en commande 52
millions notamment pour l'éducation
nationale et sur le brésil c'est pareil
on a attendu on a dit oui c'est
compliqué et ses appuis finalement tout
le monde a montré du doigt les
gens qui arrivent par milliers du brésil
et on a dit bon on va faire quelque
chose madoré gens qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ce que dit hervé marseille
quand ils estiment que l'exécutif ne
réagit finalement que sous la pression
des oppositions dont je pense pas être
d'accord avec arme et recel
le contraire nous aurait été exactement
le contraire m'aurait étonné non sur il
parle par exemple du brésil moi je pense
que le président de la république et le
gouvernement ont fait attention de
prendre les bonnes mesures au bon moment
sur la fermeture des frontières sur ce
contrôle des frontières et de ne pas
utiliser de pas utiliser ses frontières
comme un symbole politique et ça ça me
semble être la bonne décision parce
qu'on rentre vite sur ces questions là
dedans une forme de populisme
les vaccins et bien on le sait on est
directement liée à la production
cette production elle est mondiale donc
elle engendre des contraintes on a fait
le choix de faire une stratégie
européenne je pense que c'était justifié
parce que comment aurais tant que tu
comprends on se retrouve en concurrence
avec les avants ou avec les italiens
donc les mesures sont prises encore une
fois au bon moment je crois je me rappel
en janvier
tout le monde disait qu'il fallait
confiné finalement le réseau public a
fait un choix contraire ensuite tout le
monde s'en est réjoui bon voilà on est
dans des cycles politique là dedans qui
comme moi je comprends pas trop
j'ai alors qu'un jour quand même je ne
sais pas qu à mais on sortira de ce
discours là le président de la
république il a bien tout fait il a tout
décidé au bon moment etc
il a surtout depuis le début décider
tout seul de tout et ça c'est ici à des
lots sont donc il faudra tirer celle là
en est une c'est qu'on ne peut pas gérer
une crise de cette ampleur de cette
manière là et ça épuise la population
qui attend les interventions
présidentielles tous les acteurs dans la
société les acteurs locaux dans les
collectivités territoriales dans les
professions qui sont prêts à participer
à des solutions qui sont responsables
qui propose pas n'importe quoi ont tous
les doutes le sentiment de ne pas être
écoutés
tout ça n'est pas le cas mais c'est
pourtant malheureusement le cas il ya
tellement de gens qui ont le sentiment
de ne pas pouvoir apporter leur pierre
de ne pas être écoutés parce que ça ne
dialogue pas suffisamment donc je dis
pas que c'est facile mais quand on
tirera les leçons cette crise j'espère
le plus vite possible
il faudra quand même se poser des
questions sérieuses sur la manière de
rejeter a été géré la crise et sans
parler de problèmes de fond que cette
crise révèle haut niveau par exemple
récemment on a dit que la médecine du
travail joue un rôle marginal
c'est un vrai problème pourquoi les
réseaux pour ya plus de médecine
scolaire il ya une médecine du travail
qui est famélique
donc tout ça joue un rôle dans des
moments où il faudrait au contraire une
mobilisation sanitaires nationales sont
qu'il ya plein de questions à se poser
donc je dis pas qu'on pouvait tous
toutes les résoudre je veux pas faire de
la démagogie sur ça mais mais de grâce
par contre arrêté avec un discours où le
président de la république il a tout
bien fait de a à z au bon moment et ces
noms ayant un regard au moins un petit
peu plus sérieux un peu plus lucide sur
tout ce qu il faudra regarder avec quand
même un d'esprit critique le moment
merci de me dire que je regarde pas
c'est avec un regard sérieux
en l'occurrence que je constate c'est
que le choix qui a été fait de ne pas
confiné en janvier et est un choix qui
s'est avéré bon parce qu'il a permis de
excusez moi parce qu'il a permis de
compte nous a permis à tous de conserver
un minimum de vie normale et ensuite le
jeu un choix des mesures supplémentaires
ont été prises parce qu'effectivement la
situation a évolué vous ne pouvez pas
dire qu'on pouvait tout anticipé dans
cette crise je ne dis pas que tout a été
parfait
personne n'aurait fait ça parfaitement
et ça n'a pas été le cas dans quelques
pays que ce soit qui excusez moi je
termine je me suis je vous ai pas
interrompu qui file ensuite tiré un rex
d'une crise comme ça je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec vous je vous
dis juste qu'il faut pas le faire dans
la poule dans la polémique politicienne
mais moi je fais pas de la polémique je
dis que quand on le fera j'espère qu'on
n'en sera pas à se dit en permanence
tout a été bien fait à tous
non c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est
passé laissez pas les leçons qu'il
faudra tirer parce que de cette leçon il
faudra quand même tiré beaucoup
d'enseignements sur ce ce qui fait que
nous n'étions pas prêts lui malgré un
léger pardon pas uniquement politique
d'ailleurs oui bien sûr non mais à tous
les niveaux mais ça ça passe par le fait
d'écouter quand même ce qui se dit et
parfois les critiques qui sont faites et
qui sont pas tous deux fait de manière
responsable
on va écouter il ya justement ce qu'on
pense gilbert de ray puisque vous
représentez ici quand même la voix du
sanitaire aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
vous sentez un petit peu mis de côté par
rapport à la décision politique par
exemple à l'instant moins de gens
disaient bon bah c'était une bonne
décision de ne pas d'avoir choisi de ne
pas re confiné en janvier d'avoir
d'avoir laissé ce temps-là au français
est ce que vous le comprenez vous est-ce
que cela vous paraît pour vous anormal
ou papa responsables d'alors mange
minuscule totalement du champ politique
donc d'un point de vue strictement sa
liste que ça plaise ou non
les choix de ne pas confiné pour moi
était une grave erreur et je vais faire
un retour d'expérience 1 quels sont les
pays qui vont bien sur le plan sanitaire
sur le corps social tant sur le plan
économique ce sont soit les pays qui ont
fait le zéro qu'ovide vers l'asie
l'australie la nouvelle zélande sont des
pays qui ont une politique qui s'en
approche comme le danemark ou la norvège
et ils vont beaucoup mieux qu'eux donc
depuis un an nous avons commis l'erreur
de vouloir vivre avec le virus qui nous
ont mis dans sanitaire qui est pas bon
on va fêter ou à célébrer a évidemment
fait était une source de la célébration
morbide les cent mille morts et on sait
maintenant puisqu'on a un retour
d'expérience que même sur le plan
économique son plan sociétal
c'était pas le bon choix et donc je
pense que ça a été malheureusement une
erreur sanitaire je la regrette et
évidemment mon adn de médecins ne peux
pas accepter
cent mille morts des centaines de
milliers de copies de l'ong des
déprogrammations par centaines de
milliers donc je n'adhère pas tu as là
ce qui d'ailleurs me rend inquiet pour
les trois prochains mois mais je vais
dire si vous permettez de riz aux autres
choses la première c'est que nous
sortirons de la crise grâce aux vaccins
nous sortirons de la crise j'espère
d'ici fin 2021 on dit ce qu'on épargne
cours pessimiste il est optimiste
et la deuxième chose je ne veux pas
quitter ce plateau ça en devenait le mot
kovacs kowarsky n'a rien à voir lors de
discussions c'est une institution qui
vise à faire vacciner pays qu il notre
devoir moral que les pays low soient
vaccinés au rythme actuel ce sera dans
dix ans et en plus il se trouve que ça
rejoint notre intérêt car s'ils ne sont
pas vaccinés l'épidémie nous reviendra
avec des variants il faut que ce mot
kovacs soit cité encore et encore et
bien voilà c'est fait le mot de la fin à
fabrice bonnot pour savoir pour
reprendre un peu les mots de pierre
laurent est ce que vous vous vous sentez
aujourd'hui suspendu à la parole
présidentielle
et bien pour l'avenir de votre commerce
dans quel état d'esprit êtes vous alors
que on le voit emmanuel macron joue gros
auprès de beaucoup de personnes dans
dans ses décisions sanitaires oui on
attend un cap du président un cas précis
pour qu'on puisse nous anticipé
justement cette reprise
re motiver les équipes voilà donc on a
besoin d'avoir des dates précises pour
pouvoir penser réouvrir nos restaurants
dans quelques semaines voire quelques
mois
eh bien merci merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à ce débat les rangs
des bad allons plus loin demain vous
avez rendez vous avec un rayonnement de
chimie et bonjour chez vous dès 7h30
elle recevra notamment sophie cluzel la
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur public sénat